faisons prélude à la marche du siècle de
mercredi prochain sur notre chaîne le
point et france inter rendu public un
sondage concernant les adolescents et
l'amour qui indique que 61% des 15 16
ans pense qu'il faut être amoureux pour
faire l'amour contre 36% qui déclare que
non et que les muffins lettres d'amour
sont toujours d'actualité est-ce qu'il
faut être amoureux pour faire l'amour
vega toi je conçois pas qu'on puisse
faire l'amour sans votre amoureuse oui
je pense ouais ouais quand même moi
c'est important quand même on peut pas
faire l'amour à quelqu'un juste physique
est ce que vous dites facilement je
t'aime
non non pas du tout non pourquoi
parce que c'est pas banal mais ça comme
on dit bonjour denis potvin de dire quoi
ça et on sait où on ne sait pas mais moi
je dis pas je me sens un peu nul de dire
je t'aime maintenant bon voilà c'est un
peu dépassé à mon avis moi j'aime bien
comme le 10 mai le dire c'est autre
chose
à quel âge vous concevez le premier
rapport sexuel personnellement j'ai
conçu à six jeunes donc crois que par un
bandage conséquent innocence et qu'aucun
40 ans jamais couru dans la forme et le
poids de problèmes
est-ce que vos parents il accepterait
que vous veniez habiter chez eux avec
votre petite amie
oui je pense qua non maintenant ils sont
mieux parfois je pense que oui en cas de
déception sentimentale ou est ce que
vous trouvez le réconfort dans le
frigidaire vous pourrez boulimie l'amour
ça fait mal oui